if I want a free vacation of my choice I
would go to Italy the reason I would go
there is because is I would love to see
the country's difference beautiful
sights in attractions as well as eat
their delicious food first I would go to
the beaches I would love to hang out on
the warm beautiful beaches of the
Italian coastline in and hang out in the
the crystal blue waters of the
Mediterranean Sea then I would go visit
roman ruins such as Pompey and of course
nearby Mount Vesuvius after that I would
go to Rome to see such sites as the
Colosseum and the Vatican I think Italy
would be the best place to go because I
think is one of the most beautiful
places in the world I have to tell you
some tips for success in the geography
bee first of all you should not cram the
information into your head the night
before the be that will not help you in
any way and you won't learn anything nor
will you have fun and that's what it's
all about so what you got to do is learn
it over time and gradually your
knowledge will increase and you'll be
good to go second what you need a few
tools for success the three most
important tools would be atlases and
geography books google earth and an
interactive globe those will tell you
where a place is what it looks like and
it will also tell you all about it last
of all the geography is is more than
just
as capitals and places on a map it's
also cultures there's transportation
economics foods people governments
infrastructure everything not just
what's the capital or what's the
longitude and latitude it's a very
diverse subject and most importantly
have fun if you were to visit my
hometown Danville California there's
plenty of things to see in the area and
state first of all which is nearby is
Mount Diablo right there that mountain
at a height of 3849 feet has the second
best views of any mountain in the world
second only to Mount Kilimanjaro in
Tanzania the you can see over a hundred
miles in each direction in over 35
counties on a clear day from the summit
also nearby e to the west of san
francisco over there you can you can
check out the city along with the goat
its golden gate bridge pier 39 Chinatown
cable cars all of it it's very close to
here also near there is is the beautiful
California coastline with redwood
forests rocky cliffs and crystal blue
waters there's across the Central Valley
and into the Sierra Nevada is Lake Tahoe
a large mountain lake that as a second
deepest in the country it is a popular
place for hurt skiing and snowboarding
in winter and for hiking and just plain
relaxing in summer it's a beautiful
forested area also to the south is
Yosemite National Park Yosemite Valley
is famous for all of its granite it
mountains there such as half dome in El
Capitan it's a beautiful place to see
south of there is Sequoia National Park
famous for its giant sequoia trees the
largest being called General Sherman the
largest living thing on earth then if
you're in California no trip is complete
without going down south check out all
the beautiful beaches as palm trees and
of course Disneyland and you might as
well check out san diego as well all all
of california is a beautiful place to
see e it is so diverse as well one place
it's rolling hills another place it's
tall mountains to Lush valleys to
deserts so come see California it's a
nice place I strongly really encourage
you to participate in the Geography Bee
it's fun it's a great way to learn about
geography and well you never know where
it may take you good luck
you